[Music]
there's one thing about the documentary
I find absolutely unbelievable which is
there's a lot of things probably but go
ahead no no there's one specific thing
okay that I do not believe would poison
I do not believe it's not about food
poisoning I don't believe that five guys
can be in a room at 2:00 in the morning
and only one of them orders pizza and
nobody else has a bite of the pizza
crazy just heard an excerpt from the
director about this he was on another
podcast and he was saying the story is
apparently everybody ordered dinner
without Michael Jordan earlier and so
like they didn't wait on him and he got
there late or something they all ate
without him so he was pissed off at
everybody
so he's like fine let's find food I got
to eat pizza is the only thing that's
open they're not in Salt Lake City in
downtown yeah for some reason their
hotels like on the outskirts it's
believable that pizzas do the sheets it
comes in MJ says none of you guys are
eating this I'm gonna eat on it and then
he spits on the pizza so nobody else can
eat it sounds like I'm Jo here's the
thing so I believe that he wanted a
pizza to himself right I also believe
you're a six six athletic machine you
key the whole pizza to yourself I could
eat a whole pizza to myself right it's
not that hard yeah I don't believe that
you would order only one pizza I think
if there's five got five people or five
guys are in a room or however many guys
were hanging out but it seems like
there's a you you really think five
dudes are gonna share one pizza if we
order right now four of us are about to
order pizza we're gonna one single pizza
MJ knew he was eating that pizza by
himself nobody else ordered pizza yeah I
don't buy it I think that is the only
fictitious thing going on here I don't
know what got him sick I don't know if
there was partying drugs who the [ __ ]
knows but I do not buy that a pizza was
ordered and nobody else was like yeah
just get two why not it's a life of
luxury this so you just buy bottles
you're just frivolous I also your stupid
license plate on my Range Rover
I'm a little skeptical that five dudes
come and deliver a pizza and then my
personal trainer who I've been with for
over a decade now says hey man something
about this doesn't seem right I'm gonna
be like yeah you know what let me eat
the whole thing before the finals Game
five can I can I do five dudes
delivering the pizza makes the most
sense to me especially if they're not
poisoning it think about it if you were
gonna poison Michael Jordan why would
more of you go and wave your hand and
beg hey look who gave you the food
poisoning to me it's like oh [ __ ] we're
delivering a pizza to the hotel where
the bowls are staying everybody at that
pizza store and their friends are going
it might be Michael Jordan let's just
all go right
maybe it's Kai Piven maybe it's Robin
right still cool [ __ ] it luc longley
we'll take it what's going to hotel with
the Bulls right it's gotta be the Bulls
right they're all showing up they're
admitting guilt if they all show up the
second there were like five guys came to
hotel I was like nope not food poisoning
no way in [ __ ] hell it can't see that
makes sense right you're admitting it's
like only a rapper would be so dumb to
like say they did the crime Oh what
these guys are doing I need a real
doctor not just an Indian to verify this
but my understanding is food poisoning
takes like 36 hours to really take hold
of it's like I can push back on that
from personal experience and Jamil can
attest to it what happened we both had
the same sandwich but his metabolism is
way quicker than mine I guess he got
sick quicker boy we were living together
and he was throwing up in the bathroom I
was like you stupid [ __ ] idiot you
crazy lettuce you [ __ ] two hours later
I was like [ __ ] idiot funny okay fair
enough but yeah I don't know sketchy
right but Tim Grover has always thought
it was food poisoning I remember I read
his book and he said I think was food
poisoning five guys delivered and I felt
weird about it this is day okay let me
throw something at you also real quick
if you're Jordan a guy who believes what
he believes and you can't convince him
differently if he thinks it was food
poisoning nothing will change his mind
that's the story he's gonna stick with
forever if he thinks his food poison I
think it was food poisoning but I don't
it was intentional okay it's late it's
the last place open I'm pretty sure they
just have [ __ ] sitting out it probably
went a little bad or whatever the case
is like that's just a [ __ ] that's a
chance there's a chance there's a chance
I've worked at a piece of place yeah I
spent my childhood working a pizza place
dude the pizzas would be out for [ __ ]
days and we would eat them nothing goes
bad like the cheese is so processed like
everything is so [ __ ] what about the
meats like you have the pepperonis and
all that [ __ ] out pepperonis dried
right so it's like it's already
precooked you can leave pepperoni out
for I know your your thing is
interesting and sometimes Quinta this
happen and when they happen to like
great people we're like uh-huh
something's going on here right but like
if you and I can get food poisoning so
can Michael Jordan but when it happens
then like there's an attack right so I
think that could be it or what I thought
was really interesting did you guys pick
up on they left a scene with Jerry Sloan
in the press conference where he goes
was Michael sick I don't know he's sick
yeah why leave that it I'm almost like I
know this is Jordan's people I think
Jordan thinks Jerry Sloan did some [ __ ]
to him you think so many I took it as
they were just showing his humor oh sure
he was being sarcastic talking about
Jordan being said no [ __ ] talk okay I
guess it was Jordan sick I hadn't heard
it I'm off it because I first saw it he
had me convinced and I guess I wasn't
looking at Sloane through that like like
sarcastic came-- like a coach lens you
know you see a lot of the other game he
was like oh maybe Jordan like Sloane so
he chose him in like hey look at his
light moments like he's still got a
sense I kind of like Popovich being
funny in a press conference yeah when
Jerry Sloan is just kind of like a sense
of humor about getting blown out like
okay this is it that's if Popovich said
that I'd be like always being sarcastic
I just didn't I wasn't familiar with
Sloan enough fair complete with some
that just hit me
black people are sensitive to lactose
well some people are more like you once
you hit a threshold then it bothers you
so say I can have one slice of pizza but
if I have eight slices of pizza
yeah and I'm [ __ ] for days maybe his
selfishness like nobody else is having
his pizza but me yeah and because he ate
too much pizza that could have been it
but he's he throwing up you ever thrown
up from lactose I begin diarrhea
sometimes I can't fathom that Michael
Jordan is lactose intolerant
I just can't found that something that
[ __ ] ass would be part of Michael
Jordan you see him he looks like death
Ameen still believes it's a hangover
Michael Jordan yeah I've never been
hungover obviously so I don't know what
it looks I just the [ __ ] look in his
there's that I think he like dunks it
and then he just kind of like touches
his wrist like this looks mad exhausted
and like pathetic almost a success
hangover that's a hangover here to me it
looks like dehydration man what is a
hangover what is the definition of a
hangover you get the IV which he got
before the game and it's like the
hangover cure now that's true getting an
IV will snap you out of the hangover
because I think I hangover all it is is
your body reacting to dehydration yeah
right so then you get those fluids in
your body and you should be [ __ ] good
to go so maybe it is something bigger
than the hangover or maybe they just
exaggerated it who [ __ ] knows I just
didn't believe the pizza thing I don't
want to take too much time on that I
just didn't buy the pizza excuse and he
really like stomped his foot about it
you know like yeah it was weird it was
like it was almost like he was on the
stand he was like I eat the pizza no one
else ate the pizza and pointing it about
that at that point I do think
something's fishy about it because then
you try to give too many details that's
usually a sign your life point out I'm
the only one who ate the pizza like
everybody is happy for some reason felt
the need to point that out like he's the
only person who made the pizza is that
Pizza Cape Cod people she is a
psychopath enough though to be upset at
people for ordering without them and
then saying I'm gonna eat this whole
pizza myself there's somebody in this
room who would probably do something
like that
[Laughter]
[Applause]